And that's it. This is the only future
strategy that I have to use. What is
going on guys? Mr. Zinc here. In today's
video, I am breaking down my new
favorite firm, Top One Futures. The
single trading strategy that I use to
get this $1,500 payout you see here, and
how I use their platform. Let's get
right into it. First things first, let's
take a look at the how. How did I get
this $1,500 payout? And how do I expect
to get another $3,000 later this week?
That strategy is as simple as the power
of 50 London strategy. That's right.
I've already made a video on this. I
will link it right here. This is the
simplest strategy I've come across. I'm
so blessed that I found it. Just
stumbled upon it one night realizing
that almost every time frame, every
session lines up with the 50% somehow.
The initial strategy itself was just
looking at London. So London, you mark
out the London high. And by London, what
I mean is 4:00 a.m. to 9:30 New York
open. I know London sessions a little
bit earlier than that, but I refer to
this as London
trading. You mark out London high and
London low, and you use your gone box
tool. Your gone box is what gives me
this 50%
drawn. Use your gan box tool, draw out
the London high and the London low. wait
on the 15minute time frame for price
action to break and then retest the
power of 50. In this case, this morning
I took a long right here at 9:45. We
wicked back down after breaking the
power of 50 from London. Wicked back
down. I took an entry, secured it for
about 50 bucks. We came and wicked back
down to it again. I took another entry,
secured it for another 30 bucks. And
then price continued a little bit. About
45 minutes later, we wicked back down to
the 50 again. We had 10 minutes left on
the 15-minute candle. I was confident
that that was probably a false move for
the first five minutes of the candle. I
re-entered longs. Got out of those for
about $70 profit. Let's go ahead and do
a live login to my top one futures
account. I am trading two accounts.
That's why it says leader. And this
account has also already taken a $1,500
payout. So, the true value of this
account is actually 28,100
uh minus500 to the payout. I am up 229
today. Go ahead and look at our
performance stats. This strategy has
about a 72% win rate. The strategy
itself, I bet, is a bit higher than
that. Uh sometimes I tilt. I am still
getting used to futures. I'm by no means
perfect in trading futures. I am much
better than I used to be. Uh everyone
struggles with futures. I am no
exception. Neither
is those big names in the industry.
Jadecap, Keen Capital. I'm sure they had
some struggles in the beginning, but now
you can see where they are on their
trading journey. So, here is my profit,
my P&L, profit factor, uh, best day
percent, total profits, yada yada. So,
here's the $1,500 payout right here. I
took it on Saturday. It was within my
account, my bank account within three
hours, which is pretty awesome.
Um, and then all the other stats if you
want to go and pause the video, look
through these. I mostly go long. I do go
short from time to time, but about 70%
of the time I am going
long. Going over to the chart itself, as
you can see, I have the 50% drawn in
here as well. I only use the 15minut
time frame. I I do not defer to any
other time frame, the five minute, the 4
hour, the daily. I only use the 15-minut
time frame. I use Trading View because
Trading View, I believe, is a little bit
more accurate than Project X. Nothing
wrong with this. I just prefer Trading
View. And then I take my entry on
Project X. Again, two accounts followed
with each other. This one is ready to
take a $1,500 payout. I need to make
another 300 here. And then that will be
another 1,500. And then this account
just needs to make another 400 bucks.
And I will take another $1,500 payout.
That's how I expect to get 3,000 this
week. The strategy itself, the power of
50, that is all you do. You wait for the
break, retest that 50% and then go long
or short depending on what side of the
50% you're on. The other thing that I
prefer to do, and it's also known as
equilibrium. I believe Trades has a
video on that. Previous day
equilibrium, draw out previous day low
to previous day high for the entire New
York session. And this is including the
4:00 a.m. to 9:30 a.m. open and then the
extended hours. In this case, we didn't
make a high in the extended hours, but
the low of the day was from the
pre-market session all the way at 4:45
in the morning. Again, what happens when
price breaks and then retests? And it's
almost unbelievable how accurate this
is. This is down to the cent uh five
cents a cent in this case.
We broke out, came and retested. I just
took longs at 11:30 and then took those
for another $50 gain that is going
towards this $229 profit in the day. As
you can see, all my trades for the day
are right here. I do take quite a few. I
know they're not any home run hits, but
that helps with my consistency rule.
That's why I have so many trades on the
day. I am only taking one MNQ, but it is
as simple as that. Every time that we
retest the power of 50, London session,
New York session, whatever it might be,
I average in with one MNQ at a time. As
long as we don't close below on the 15
minute, that is my stop loss. If we have
a close below the power of 50 on the
15minut time frame, that is my stop
loss. As long as we don't close below
it, I will gladly add into the position
up to about 3 M and Q and then I will
trail out or scale out of my position as
we continue higher. But that's the
strategy you use the power of 50. Again,
I will link the video um at the end of
the video or I'll link it somewhere
through throughout the video and you can
click on it, go watch that video, and
then come back here. That is as simple
as that. That's the only indicator that
I use. It's not really an indicator.
It's just a drawing tool, the gone box.
Draw the tool. Go to settings on the
gone
box. Activate zero, 0.5, and one. And
that's all you need.
Going over to the account itself and
explaining the rules on top one. This is
a lot of confusion here. The rules
aren't all that complicated. Going to
the dashboard. I'm going to explain what
the consistency rule is, how it works
with payouts, and how it works after you
get a payout. First things first is the
consistency rule itself is set to 20%
for instant funded accounts, 25% for
express uh eval accounts. What those
eval accounts mean is that you're going
to have to take an eval phase or an
evaluation phase where you need to hit,
let's say, $3,000 in profit without
having a $2,000 loss in the account to
reward you. They give you another 5%
consistency. So, you could take a payout
every four days as opposed to every
five. I prefer the instant funded just
because you skip the eval phase. You get
started on making your real money, money
in your hand. right away. So, the
consistency
rule means that at 20% consistency, your
best day's profit is 15th of what your
total profit goal is before you can take
a payout. Going over to my daily
summary, we can see that my best profit
day was
557.52. So, go whip out your calculator.
557.52* 5 gives you 2787.6.
6. You go over to your profit. Keep that
number in mind.
2787.6. Go over to your profit. I'm up
2372.82. Using that
557.52* 5 because that's our 20%
consistency. We subtract
2,372.82. That gives us
414.78. That is how much money I have
left to make before I can take a payout
on this account. Max payout for the 25k
account is 1,500. As you can see, my
balance will be about
2,800. I will more than be able to take
that $1,500 payout and then still have
$1,300 left in the account to trade
with. That is how the consistency rule
works for your first payout. For your
second payout, your consistency resets.
So, as you can see, I took a $1,500
payout on uh May 3, didn't trade on
Sunday, and now took a a series of
trades today for $229 in profit. That is
my new consistency goal. That is now my
new best day. So,
229.74* 5. I need to make
$1,148 total before I can take another
payout from this account. However, as
you can see, my profit is way more than
another 1,500. 1,500,500 $3,000. I'm
already well over 3,000. I need to make
another $1,000 before I take a payout.
So, my account will be about
$4,200. I can take another max payout,
another $1,500 this Friday if every
trade I take or every winning day that I
take is
$229.74. If not, I'll just take the
payout next Monday. So be it. But that
is how the consistency rule on this firm
works. Your consistency is reflected on
what your best P&L day
is. And simple as that. I know it's a
little confusing at first and people are
like, "Hey, why why do I want to use
this as opposed to Topzip or Tradeify or
all these other firms?" The reason that
I like this one so much is after you get
your buffer built up, my buffer is 3,200
bucks. After you get your buffer built
up, that second payout is incredibly
easy. And after three payouts, you get
moved live. They joint uh or combine all
your accounts, excuse me. They combine
all your accounts. So, in this case, I
have 200 225K instant funded. They're
both sitting at about 3,000 profit. They
will move me to live and put up to
10% of the entire account's value into
profit. Since I am under that 10%
threshold, they'll put the full $6,000
into the live funded. They will merge
it. I'll have $50,000 in funded on live
plus $6,000 in P&L. I'll be trading an
account at 56,000. And the rules to it
are the same, I believe, as the 25K. You
can trade uh 10 minis or one micro. I I
just trade one MNQ at a time using the
power of 50 as we previously covered.
And that's that. As for the payouts and
the platform itself, the platform
yourself, uh the platform itself, excuse
me, is extremely easy to use. It's very
very easy to use. I just do the buy one
market and then when I want to close the
position, I click the X over here.
Closes it automatically for me. And then
that's my profit for the day. Again, I
do take a lot of trades, but my trades
have a a pretty low low number for best
trade or average winning trade. There
you go. Average winning trades 44 bucks.
Average losing trades negative 53. Uh
but my win rate is 71%. So that's
clearly outweighing it to the winning
side. Pretty good riskreward there.
About one to one, a little bit less than
one to one. And then once you get to
your profit goal, so again it's 5x, 20%
is the consistency target. 5x is your
profit goal. If I make 500 bucks, my
profit goal is 2500 before I get the
payout. Once you get the payout, the
platform updates real time. So you can
take that payout any time during the
day. The platform itself updating real
time is huge as most other firms update
at the end of the day or even at six
o'clock EST and then you have to wait
for the following business day to start
your payout process and then you end up
getting that money 3 to 5 days later
after um you finalized or submitted your
payout. You need your payout approved
and then you get your payout. There's a
long process. This one again was three
hours. three hours after I submitted my
payout, I got that money within my bank
account, which is it's just crazy to
think. Again, I only have uh two
accounts on top one. These are the two
SIM funds that I purchased, two 25K
accounts. This is my first $1,500 payout
with them. I expect to get another one
either tomorrow or Wednesday and then I
should have another payout by Friday so
long as I as I trade well for the rest
of the
week. Finally, going over to the
strategy again and just reassuring how
simple this is. The strategy is stupid
simple. There's no question about it. Is
one box I draw on the chart. It's the
power of 50. There's no complication to
it. All you do is wait. That's the
hardest part about the strategy is
waiting for it to go and connect with
the 50% of the day. As you can see,
Friday's price action May 2nd, we had a
pretty crazy ramp up. This went from all
the way down at 481 up to 491 at high
day as a $10 move on Q's in less than
one day, less than 24 hours. That's one
trading day.
$10 move up. To take a trade after this
$10 move up, you have to wait for price
to retrace back down to that
50%. As you can see, we did. That was
where our new week opening gap was. We
reacted to the
50%. Beautiful short
opportunity. Excuse me. Next thing you
do, you wait for price to react again at
the 50%. In this case, we broke over,
came back down, retested, and continued
to push up. Beautiful entry on the trade
there. That's how simple the power of 50
is. And the power of 50 is not
rebranding it to anything. That's just
saying the power of 50%. That is how
good the 50% is on any time frame. Even
if you want to use it on the 24 time,
24-hour time frame, look for larger
retracements on this high to low macro
time frame. Hey, if I want to go long
for an extended period of time, I'll
wait for price to retrace back down to
445. I found that it works the best on
the 15 minute time frame. 15 minute is
uh much shorter than the hour time
frame. So you don't have to wait as
long, but it's 3x as long as the five
minute time frame. So you avoid fake
outs. In this case, there was two fake
outs at this stage. On the five minute,
whereas if we look at the 15-minute,
there was no fake outs. We just had nice
wicks to that power 50 and then a
continuation.
Top one is currently running a 55% off
promo with code zinc. Uh the other promo
code is payouts for 50% or you can use
my code for 55% off. I will drop the
link to top one in the description of
the video. I will release more videos
later this week on uh further going into
the power of 50, exactly how I use it
and then where I trade live every day.
Hopefully get some more payouts to show
you guys the end of this week. But that
is my full review on my trading strategy
as to how I got that $1,500 payout on
top futures and how I use top one
futures. That will do it for today's
video. Hope all you guys have a great
rest of your day. Peace out.